hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
this right here is Apple's brand-new 16
inch MacBook Pro it's actually fully
Specht out with a 2.4 gigahertz 8 quart
i 9 processor 32 gigabytes of ram and
the highest end 5500 m 8 gigabyte
graphics card and in this video we're
going to be testing gaming performance
playing Call of Duty's all new modern
warfare and we're also going to be
testing out a couple of benchmarks
Unigine Heaven and 3d marks time spy and
we're going to compare this model to the
base 5300 M 4 gigabyte graphics to see
if it's actually worth spending the
extra cash the extra 200 dollars to get
the fully specked out graphics for
gaming now I want to remind you guys
that these graphics cards just got the
very first drivers for Windows 10 using
boot camp so they might have some
glitches or some performance issues and
performance should generally improve
over time so let's get right into it and
see how much FPS we can get on the 16
inch macbook pro alright guys so here I
am in boot camp on the fully spec doubt
16 inch MacBook Pro with the 2.4
gigahertz eye 9 8 core CPU and the best
graphics with 8 gigabytes of video
memory so let's get right into college
ooty modern warfare
so first things first I've got to fix
these textures because I think it's a
driver issue so right this is weird I'm
gonna I'm gonna switch the settings
right now see I'm gonna turn down the
texture resolution a little bit because
I'm not sure what's going on here
textures are still screwed up but fps is
better you definitely don't need this
much fps
whoa what is going on so 150 FPS still
still looking good oh I'm gonna go into
the options I'm going to set the render
resolution to 75 now let's see what that
does
75 that's 1440p looks like now we're
honestly averaging around 50 60 FPS so
the fans are definitely really loud but
luckily the speakers are also really
good and really loud as well or of
course you can wear headphones while
playing on the MacBook Pro definitely
seeing around 70 FPS with these settings
which is actually that's like the sweet
spot you want to be a little bit higher
so that when it dips down it goes down
to 60 and not much lower than that so
the only issue is that we're still
experiencing these weird glitched
graphics graphics I'm gonna turn down
the texture resolution down to low
that's all off let me turn off these
cache spot shadows let me see if that
actually helps I'll turn the resolution
back to normal and see how that plays
alright so those shadows are now off
still getting about 75 70 FPS to be
honest I think these are the best
settings right here I'll show you guys
in just a minute it's working incredibly
well so far so I still don't know what's
up with these textures they're really
really messed up
luckily the FPS is fine but the textures
are just screwed up right now really
screwed up and look at that the FPS is
still good at around 70 sometimes it
dips down to 60 which is fine
any lower than that you don't really
want almost got him in the face so what
they screwed up textures when we get new
drivers out it's definitely gonna
improve so that's gonna go away and the
FPS is actually gonna get better as well
so that's really nice that we're getting
this much FPS around 70 so far yeah I
get him in the face oh he's up there
right so real quick let me show you guys
those settings again we're at 2304 by
1440 that's 75% render resolution going
down where our normal textures low on
those all the shadows are either
disabled or low and right now we're
getting really good framerate around 70
FPS with dips going down to 60 so I'd
say this is pretty good
got so close almost had you bro Oh got
him
so I'd say buying a 16 inch MacBook Pro
and being able to play some games on the
side definitely pretty nice you know
buying it for a Productivity kind of
stuff so far I'm extremely impressed
because you usually don't play at 1440p
on a laptop and we were able to play at
that resolution at around 70 FPS average
and that's with brand new drivers that
are definitely having issues as you guys
saw with all those graphics glitches and
everything else now we did actually play
with the base $2,400 16 inch macbook pro
that's packing the 5300 M 4 gigabyte
graphics now before I tell you how that
performed let me quickly go through a
couple of the benchmarks that we ran and
show you the differences between the two
now in Unigine heavens' xtreme preset
there actually wasn't that much of a
performance boost going to the more
expensive graphics and interestingly
there actually wasn't a big difference
between Windows and Mac OS for that test
so that could mean that the drivers are
still underperforming and windows or
that can mean that Mac OS is actually
catching up with gaming performance
we're not exactly sure we'll see how
that newer drivers perform after this
now we also tested 3d marks times by
benchmark and to our surprise the base
model actually scored higher than the
higher-end model which doesn't really
make any sense we're not sure why this
happened maybe it's driver issues or
something like that but in modern
warfare the base model actually
performed exactly the same as the
higher-end model we got around 70 FPS
average on both of these machines at
1440p and it's interesting that the VRAM
usage on both of these machines was
under three gigabytes so right now it
looks like you don't need the extra four
gigabytes with the highest-end 5500 M
eight gigabyte model in seeing how both
of these machines actually got the same
fps right now it does not make sense to
spend the extra hundred or the extra two
hundred dollars on the better graphics
card so if you're planning on doing some
gaming the base graphics will actually
be fine for you right now because
getting 75 FPS at 1440p is actually
really really nice so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you did definitely
click that circle above to subscribe
because we've got some more videos on
the 16 inch macbook pro coming up very
soon and if you want to check out some
more of those videos we've got some
right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]